uh I want to ask you specifically about
that that last step back with like a
minute or so to go the last step back
that you hit uh just kind of what was
can you just walk me through your
thought process on that play that you
know going into it you obviously we've
seen you hit that before but um just
kind of what was your read on that how
you I think we was up two um so it was
uh you know you I'm always paying
attention to what the coaches are saying
and you know what the bench is saying I
always got my ear to that you know so I
know if they going to try to run that
guy you know a couple possession before
that I heard them telling them the guy
next like get ready you go you go so it
was like I knew I wasn't going to have
space to attack so I kind of just baited
him I held it and I attacked a little
bit knowing I was going to have to get
off the ball uh but that time I kind of
stayed higher up the floor because I
knew like it was a chance that they
would run somebody at me but once I
stayed up and I saw that it was just me
and him uh one-on-one I was like um I'm
going to try to get to a spot you know
I'm going to get to some my comfort
spots and um he pressed up on me and um
I had got around him a few times so I
kind of hit the gas to get him on his
heels and then I changed Direction and
he tried to cut that move off and then I
changed direction again and by the time
I did that and went into my step back I
had enough space to get a a clean look
so um that's a look that I take seven
days a week so um you know it was a
comfort shot once I got into my my shot
pocket and he contested it it was the
ball was already where I needed it to be
so it was a pretty much a clean shot for
me and if I can get that type of
opportunity I'm going to take it every
time and uh I also knew that it wasn't
going to be the last possession but it
was opportunity to create some distance
so um I didn't have my mind made up but
it was you know I just kind of read what
was
happening 70 burst here for
Philadelphia Damen Lillard three-pointer
applies and he's got another one Daven
Lillard doing what he does the double
team and nowhere to go now here's the
one before just oneon-one with Kelly UB
creates space this guy